please the hall-of-famer Phil Mickelson
joining us on the program the match
champions for charity will be played May
24th on TNT and TBS at medallist golf
club down in Florida Tiger Woods and
Peyton Manning and Tom Brady and Phil
joining us now good morning Phil how are
you good morning to ask you to be back
on your show have you been I'm good
where are you right now I'm in San Diego
and are you in your office your man cave
yes in the yeah I'm in the corner of the
office exactly what is the coolest piece
of memorabilia in the office the Masters
trophies things like that that there's
also a t-rex that's that's kind of cool
too it's a little bit older what about
non golfer what do you have golf that
would be tier at Toronto source Rex yeah
beta actually for Mongolia that Amy got
me 10 years ago which is kind of cool
just the head of course how long have
you gone without playing golf what's the
longest you've done in your professional
career where you didn't pick up a club
so probably what we just experienced the
first five weeks that we were on
quarantine I did not swing a club and it
was it was probably the longest that I
have gone without touching a club even
in the offseason I'll go play every
couple of weeks just to you know go hang
out with the guys and have fun can it be
a good thing to not pick up a club oh
yeah it is it is because what happens is
my desire comes back when I'm away from
it and it's been such a big part of my
life that when I don't have it for a
while I miss it and I remember how much
I loved it and I appreciate it more for
sure what we're seeing with the Michael
Jordan Chicago Bulls last dance you know
a lot of this is Michael and just how
competitive he is like all it feels like
all great athletes have that gene like
there's something there can you relate
at all to Michael with that desire to be
great at all cost
so I think that anybody that is
successful at a high level there there's
this selfishness to them that you you
kind of block everything else out and
the only thing that matters is
being the best and winning that
championship so I can relate somewhat
because it's very easy to get in that
trap and kind of lose the big picture if
you will in life and get so determined
on just this this one aspect and it's a
very I want to say it's a selfish thing
but it's also the trait that you have to
have to be successful have you watched
the Jordan documentary I have the I
think it's terrific you played golf with
him
I played golf with him a long time ago
and I'm actually in the process of
joining his club there in Florida the
Grove that you know which is really a
cool place he did an exceptional job
there
how do you how do you apply like well
how does that work where you you call
Michael and say I'm thinking about being
a member or you get invited you have you
have to be invited and so fortunately I
know a number of members there and I'm
going to be my wife and I just bought a
lot fairly close there it's only about
10-15 minutes away and so it would be a
great place to play in practice how good
was Jordan back when you played he's
been around a for I think I don't know
if he's still a four handicap so I
haven't played with them in a while but
I've seen him play and he seems to get
better and better and the this area that
he gets better on are the shots around
the Greens all the subtleties the
nuances putting all the intricacies the
the swing is I'm not really I haven't
seen him hit it enough to see how much
better he is but the touch around the
greens he continues to get better at who
came up with the idea to have you with
tiger and Peyton and Tom Brady that's a
good question I don't know where it
really came from there's a gentleman
Brian Zarif who does the ray Donovan
show on Showtime he's kind of our
executive producer he and I become
friends and we've been talking about the
the match for for quite a long time in
fact you know were the ones that kind of
came up with the idea years ago and
brought it to CAA and had it developed
before we've brought it to Tiger and
he's very he's got a very creative mind
and thought that the interaction between
two other players and as a partner was
going to be an important part of
improving our match because when tiger
and I came down the stretch in Vegas we
claimed
duh we didn't talk we didn't communicate
we tightened up and we needed a partner
there to to get something out of us and
so because we won't have caddies Brady
and I will be talking about each shot
club selection windbreak and so forth
it's almost like I'll be his caddy he'll
be mine and we'll be feeding off of each
other and so you'll hear a lot more
interaction plus the fact that Brady and
Manning especially is such a good smack
talker it will be entertaining because
of that you know he is so funny in the
way he delivers his lines Manning is
that you he elicits a response of
laughter rather than a defensive
response which a lot of times when
you're when you're cutting somebody up
but you can come in a little a little
hot and you can get defensive and Manny
does such a good job of making it funny
is he the best smack talker out of all
four I think so because it's so subtle
and understated and he just has a
delivery that's soft but the jabs sting
well he's got that aw shucks and he sort
of talks out the side of his mouth he's
got that Southern drawl just a little
bit just let it you know slip out a
little bit that's exactly so he he will
get the best out of tiger and I think
that he'll be the kind of the one to
deliver the smack talk and Tiger will be
the one to deliver the great shots which
is fine and then Brady and I you know
Tom and I we usually have some pretty
good responses too so I think it's going
to be a much more entertaining match
than the first one because there'll be a
lot better interactive and you've played
with Brady Peyton's played with Tiger
and you played with Tom is that how the
team's formed I think so I've played a
number of rounds with Tom now and in
fact I had one of the greatest moments
Dan of my one of those interesting
moments that occurred when I did play
with Tom it was about a week or two
before he was going to start throwing
with Edelman getting ready for training
camp and we were at Augusta National and
he asked if I would go catch some passes
I said yeah man I loved it loved it fast
Tom Brady were twenty yards away it's
7:15 in the morning and it's half dark
out and he's thrown
these balls so hard that I'm worrying
about busting a finger
I only catch the half the second half of
the pass and so if the ball wasn't on my
torso I couldn't catch it it would if it
was off to the side I would end up
missing it and I was so cautious about
bending my fingers in a way you know
having them so that I don't Jam a finger
if there were three times that a ball
hit the palm that it got through my
fingers and hit the palm I handed all
three times I had a nerve shot go right
up my arm and I thought that's gotta be
so hard to be running full-speed with a
helmet on bobbing up and down and have
these balls coming in with such heat and
grab him it gave me a new respect for
how good those guys are but that was one
of those unique moments and I kind of
look back on and laugh and cherish
because who gets to catch passes with
Tom Brady at Augusta National 7:15 in
the morning but imagine if he breaks
your finger and somebody says oh how did
you break your finger Tom Brady threw a
pass at me yeah so that would that would
that wouldn't be good if you looked at
either way but it was two weeks before
the master so I didn't want the Masters
because of that single toughest golf
course in the world is where that's a
that's a hard question to answer but I
would actually say Torrey Pines in San
Diego is one of the hardest for me
because when it's at sea level at
seventy six hundred yards the ball
doesn't go very far so from the tips
it's an it's the longest course I've
ever played and when you throw in some
US Open rough and firm greens like we we
get I think that's the hardest course
I've seen but a lot of people would
argue Oakmont in Pennsylvania and it
would be hard to disagree with that
I played Oakmont it makes you want to
cry like you think you're hitting a good
shot honey like you guys play it when
the greens are really fast when the
conditions are really difficult and I
played and I went I like it was a
slugfest like I was drained when I got
through I didn't enjoy it at all it's
beautiful I just didn't enjoy it so I
would agree with that is that hard
doesn't always mean better or fun I
think Oakmont maybe Torrey Pines
the hardest course it doesn't mean I
enjoy playing in fact I only like to
play once a year because it's not fun
and it beats you up every single shot
but I guess it's nice to have the
ability to be tested like that but I
always enjoy having a course that you
can reach some par fours or you you know
and and par fives you can get to and
make some birdies and short par threes
things like that those are always the
fun hold the match champions for charity
and be played May 2014 T and TBS the
medalists golf club in Florida Tigers
home course Peyton Manning Phil
Mickelson Tom Brady when do you think
your relationship changed with Tiger so
I've always appreciated and respected
what he has done for the game of golf
and what he's done for me because when
he increased the ratings
nobody benefited more than I did on the
course and off the course and and then
there was a moment in in 1991 when I won
my first PGA Tour event the entire purse
was a million dollars in the first place
cheque was a hundred eighty thousand and
as I was starting my career I thought
and wondered if there was ever be a
point where we would have a first-place
cheque of a million dollars because all
these other athletes were signing for
these big contracts and and I did not
think it would happen in my career and
Tiger comes along gets golf on the front
page and next thing you know sponsors
want in and we're playing for a
million-plus
first place check every single week now
and it's and it's been like that for
quite some time and I've always
attributed that to him and as well as
the increased opportunities off the golf
course that he has provided so I've
always had this respect for what he's
done for me and my family because
nobody's benefited more but I think our
relationship turned around 2016 when we
were working together for the Ryder Cup
he was an assistant captain and we ended
up spending a lot of time on the phone
getting ready talking about players
picks strategies alternate shot and and
course set up and all these things and
getting an idea to see how prepared he
was and meticulous with each little
thing I had a new respect for him but
when we work together for a common goal
which was to win the Ryder Cup it
brought us closer I think that was kind
of the turning
you've got a sneaky team this year in
the NFL so my sneaky team is the same
team I'm just a charger fan
unfortunately they're not the San Diego
Chargers or Los Angeles but I'm still a
charger fan I always think they're going
to be better than they are they lose
more games by a single score than any
team in the NFL and they lead in
injuries so if they can get that fixed
they have so much talent I think they
can be really fun I don't know much
about the quarterback that they drafted
Justin Herbert other than he's a really
really smart guy and a lot of talent and
I think that's a formula for success
he's got a lot of weapons around him and
I really like the GM Tom's Lesko I think
he's just a brilliant guy and he he he
brings in a lot of talent that adds to
the team not just first string but
second string to a lot of depth and I
just think they're a really good team
but they just don't play to their level
of talent or ability it just surprises
me so yet I'm here I am stuck pulling
for them every year and wish them well
if I said you could win another major or
the Chargers could win the Superbowl so
I'm a pretty selfish ass how about just
a regular tour stop or Chargers win the
Super Bowl
so if you had asked me you know years
ago about that I would say the Super
Bowl but because I'm 50 and I kind of
cherish each win from here on out I
would take a regular tour with it's
great to catch up with you I know it's
for the all in challenge and making a 10
million dollar donation to coronavirus
relief efforts and should be fun it's
great to talk to you again Phil I hope
families do well and thanks for your
time and thank for having me back on
your shows nice to be back on that's a
phil mickleson